you thank you all for coming
so yeah this is making the big data
ecosystem work together with obviously a
focus on Python although a lot of the
big data ecosystem is actually written
in Java so we'll see how that can add
some extra challenges including my
slides okay there we go um so yeah my
name is Hogan my preferred pronouns are
she or her and I'm actually a PMC member
on spark which is like a committer but
with tenure because they can't really
kick me out anymore which is lovely it's
kind of a shitty version of tenure
though because it doesn't really
guarantee a paycheck so it's like this
not very useful tenure if you're
interested in learning more about how
open source development works one of the
things which I've started doing is code
review live streams and you can follow
me on Twitch or YouTube and what I do is
as a committer one of the things that
you're responsible for doing is
reviewing code changes and so I
broadcast those so people can see the
process and maybe be slightly less
scared of contributing to open source or
at least encourage more people to
contribute to open source and I'm also a
co-author of some books they're not too
important in addition to Who I am
professionally I'm trans clear Canadian
and part of the leather community and
this isn't particularly directly related
to big data right there is no secret
Canadian
JVM debugger that we've been hiding from
you I wish there was honestly like god
damn but I think it's important to
remember that we we all come from
different places but we all face a lot
of the same challenges especially with
writing software and when we should be
nice to each other and work together
rather than being you know not so nice
to each other so please be nice to your
coworkers and remember that they may
come from different backgrounds in
yourself so I'm hoping you're all nice
people it's a Python conference that's a
pretty good sign I'm actually really
curious how many people in the audience
don't know Python it's totally okay if
you don't know Python one person yay
thank you
welcome to the community um we're really
excited to have you here and the the
examples will be in Python but
they will hopefully be easily to
understand how many people are
interested in distributed systems thank
God okay how many people really don't
care about distributed systems okay um
this is focused on distributed systems
but even if you don't care about
distributed systems I think we can learn
some interesting things about how tools
can work together in general and best
practices we can essentially learn from
the mistakes the distributed systems
ecosystem has made so we're going to
talk about how big data tools play
together then we'll talk about how big
data tools play together between Java
the JVM and Python and also other
languages I'm gonna look at a lot of
Apache projects and one non Apache
project and we'll do a bit of a deep
dive in the PI spark because I have the
most experience with that and I'll try
and get you to buy my book and subscribe
to my youtube channel because why not
there will be a lot of pictures of cats
that is the one thing I can guarantee so
how do the big data tools play together
in general so maybe you've got your data
in a sequel system and now you want to
do some machine learning on it normally
the answer is take your data save it
somewhere load it into the machine
learning system and and have fun and
this is this is really frustrating
because this pattern is repeated over
and over again with all of the different
tools in the Hadoop ecosystem it's
pretty much save your data into a file
format and have the other file have the
other system read this file back in and
pick it up
that's not too slow on local files but
when you have distributed file systems
and like terabytes of data this starts
to get really really sad then if you add
multiple languages into the mix this can
get even more complicated sometimes you
can use caf-co to like share your data
between multiple people it's better than
files but that's like a real low bar
right that's like being better than
MapReduce we kind of all got to get
there and if we don't there's some
questions and we also end up having meta
tools we have to have tools on top of
our tools to get them to play together I
have to
have a tool that will say hey what's up
I finished my ETL job now it's time to
kick off my machine learning job and
it's just like I do I have a piece of
software to run my other piece of
software to run Oh goddammit right and
that's that's fine but sometimes people
write shell scripts to do this and then
that's not so fun okay so there's a
bunch of things about this that that are
sad it's hard to test writing to disk is
slow writing to distribute a disk is
twice as slow and Kafka is comparatively
fast but not so bad and does anyone use
something like s3 or Google object store
or ibm's object store yeah okay a lot of
people so you'll you'll find this nice
property where they look a lot like HDFS
and a bunch of tools kind of work with
them but occasionally you'll get
exciting race conditions because they're
not actually HDFS and they don't make
the same guarantees so not only is our
things slow we occasionally get race
conditions from files that are partially
written and then consumed missing a
chunk and it turns out that as flexible
as our parsers may be that is not a good
time even for JSON records and so part
of this was solved to some small degree
inside a spark and it's not perfect and
we'll talk about a lot of that
shortcomings shortly but spark looked at
the big data ecosystem and said well
what about if I just put most of the
tools people want together into one
package that sounds like a solution now
admittedly that's the solution that
quickly leads to a lot of other problems
but it's a good start so for example I
can have my sequel data and my machine
learning living together in the same
system and this is kind of cool I can do
my ETL and machine learning without
writing it out to disk saving it you
know reading it back inside of another
system the downside is now my machine
learning job can crash my ETL job but
that's fine that's fine everything's
okay the other downside of this is that
there's two machine learning systems
inside of SPARC to streaming systems
inside of SPARC and there's one graph
system which doesn't work and
another graph system which I'm told
might work but we forgot to put it
inside a spark so oops um but the the
next thing to note is that we can also
access this in multiple languages and
that's really going to be what we focus
on mostly today so how do people get
Python and other non jvm languages to
work with these largely JVM based tools
it's a combination of pickling we're all
familiar to some degree maybe with
pickling if not it's it's not too bad
other times they use strings some people
use JSON someone looked at those two
three things and said you know what this
needs
Enterprise and now they use XML for data
interchange between processes on the
same computer I'm gonna argue that was
probably not an improvement and
occasionally other random custom one-off
solutions would be the polite approach
anyways and then they communicate these
over UNIX pipes sockets writing things
out to local files and occasionally if
they thought slightly further ahead but
not all the way memory map files and so
yeah essentially because we can't really
share memory very easily and we have a
very different understanding of the
world in Python and the JVM we end up
using these kind of old-school methods
of sharing data between our processes
some other people looked at that mess
and went oh god hell no that that was a
terrible idea I'm not doing that and
they said you know what the solution to
a poorly implemented tool is is I'm
gonna rewrite it but this time I'm gonna
do it purely in Python and that was a
great idea until they realized that they
had to talk to to the other data systems
and the other data systems weren't
written in Python and so we have some
really cool really cool pure systems
insofar as Python is pure it's largely
actually C code under the hood but they
just don't integrate well and so that's
sad - so okay how does this actually
apply in
and spark is that anyone actually here a
spark user yay friends and also I'm
really sorry yeah this is my job and
I'll admit I haven't done the faster
actually oh maybe I can distract you my
shoes light up see that makes the I'll
do it on the side of the stage two very
important and totally compensates for
the fact that we've been copying things
over UNIX pipes for years so it's
actually pretty mature occasionally we
forget to implement parts of spark in it
but that's okay we normally fix it when
someone tells us and the does this part
is the one which really sucks it has
some serious performance hurdles sort of
inherent in our design let's let's look
at this Oh are there any JavaScript
users for big data in the house don't be
shy any one come talk to me afterwards
um we did something really crazy with
JavaScript it's amazing anyways okay um
so yes of course this is a big data talk
I must include word count I'm I'm sorry
this is not the last you're going to see
a word count if you ever go to a big
data talk but essentially what we can
see here is this looks kind of like
Python code admittedly someone had an
interesting idea of what a Python API
looked like but you know there's lambda
expressions inside of here and those
lambda expressions are totally Python
code and that's awesome but to make it
work we use these three things or four
things one two three four for counting
oh I was gonna replace this with
something but I didn't remember to
change it to an image but so pickles
sockets pipes and JSON and let's let's
look at that so has anyone used Piper J
you and I should be friends I want you
to debug some code so Piper J is this
really cool library for making Python
talk to the JVM it's performance is
terrible but it's really cool and we we
just use it on the driver program and
that's the program which sort of
coordinates and asks for the work to
happen it doesn't do most of the work so
the fact that we use this kind of slow
thing on the driver program is ok
because it's not doing nearly as much
work this part is the part where it gets
sad when he looked at pickling and
decided to write our own custom library
that was a good plan and we now have a
version of cloud pickle ok that goes
over better yeah with odd customers or
actually worse and then we also decided
that we didn't want to just pickle our
data we also wanted to use JSON as well
because I was tired of being able to
understand what was happening and so we
have this concept called schemas where
we have this idea of what types a data
frame contains and we decided to
represent that as JSON data and we do a
bunch of copying the data back and forth
that's kind of sad so in addition to
illustrating that I do not have an
illustrator to work with this shows you
are very high quality architecture
diagram we can see on the workers we
have a Java process and this Java
process is the one receiving all of the
data and in fact actually receiving
serialized lambda expressions but it has
no idea what the hell they are and it
often doesn't understand the data and
copying it into Python and just being
like yo you got this right and pythons
like yeah cool and and if you want to
use flink it looks pretty much the same
except replace everything with a
different thing because it's European
yeah it's like the sockets um sorry that
joke was over much better in America um
anyway so how does this impact iceberg
the double serialization cost is the big
one we have to take the data serialize
it into the JVM and then that's cool but
our work is actually going to be done in
Python so we have to take that data
again Andry serialize it into a format
that python can understand and Java is
well renowned first
seating at bit operations which is
largely what pickling in the JVM looks
like and that was mild sarcasm so it's
really slow there's a bunch of other
issues they're not as important
has anyone got a PI spark error message
raise your hand
keep your hand up if you understood it
uh-huh yeah okay that's what I thought
um and this has this other property of
because we have essentially this
Frankenstein monster walking down when
it explodes we're just like I see bits
everywhere and I don't know which bodies
they're from it's very sad this this
this this monster is very it's a very
nice monster when it works it gives me
data but when it doesn't it gives me
sadness so um spark looked at all of
this and said you know what I'm just
gonna do my computation in the JVM I can
just take Python things and translate
them into Java how hard could that be
well for some things it actually works
out pretty well
right like I can see adding two numbers
and be like yeah I can add some numbers
in Java but if I try and call something
like a library
maybe Spacey works so good there is no
space see in Java I checked and so yes
be wary of distributed systems bringing
claims of usability so spark data frames
are more like sequel tables they're not
actual data frames I'm sorry for anyone
that was expecting real data frames and
what they do is essentially they say you
can't have your lambda expressions but
I'll be really fast if you write it in
this DSL and that's I mean it's not the
end of the world because the DSL isn't
like really terrible but most of us
probably like Python because of its
libraries or things we want to do with
Python and all I can do is use this DSL
and Python really Python and word count
um so it actually did say okay yeah so
that's probably true well let people use
their lambda expressions but when they
use their lambda expression the
performance will be kind of bad but when
we do things with like this nice fancy
DSL
I'll give them really good performance
and that's like a partial solution to
this problem and I have a graph that
shows you that it runs faster this graph
may or may not apply to your code so if
you have like old spark code and you
really write it into this DSL it might
run a little bit faster yeah that's at
that part at the bottom the part where
it says bad idea
well yeah that's on all of them so yeah
so there's this PR that I came up with
and I was like you know what let's use
jaedong uh-huh yeah okay well um that
was a bad idea but it actually it got to
a good point right like our problem
isn't actually that Python is slow right
it's that we're spending all of this
time copying this data around and I have
this word count on github data I don't
know why I chose github but probably
because it gave me the benchmark I was
looking for where it was like yes this
will perform almost as good as native
code and so the yellow and the green go
together and that makes them happy but
it it really it sucks right I can't use
any of my cool libraries it's JSON it's
Python to seven I want to be with the
cool kids writing Python 3 using like
Spacey totally the solution to this is
to not get away from copying data but
just make that part not suck we're still
gonna have to copy data from the JVM
into Python but we're not going to use
custom implementations of pickling in
Java we can use this fancy thing called
arrow she's coming really soon and arrow
has some other cool things that we'll
talk about too and so is the future
probably it made it into the release
spark 2.3 you can accelerate your your
UDF's you can have really nice fast
lambda expressions in in spark and in
fact I have another graph that implies
you could get a 242 times speed up this
is a lie
but it's a very nice sounding lie and
that's what software is built on yeah um
that that being said you will probably
not a guarantee right like you will
probably see a real speed up if you see
a 200 times speed-up please email me so
I can include you in the next version of
this slide as a real-world use case but
most likely you'll see like you know 1.5
X or something like that and we can use
I 1.5 is good I mean I admit it's not
200 but that's pretty close okay um so
one of the things is this is powered by
Apache Aero and essentially Apache Aero
is not just for making Java and Python
talk together it's for making all kinds
of things talk together and it's it's
pretty awesome we can use the arrow
libraries to read in park' files
directly if we don't want to touch the
JVM that being said like it's a false
sense of security don't worry it's
actually C++ code actually mostly C code
with macros oh God
or we can use something on top of the
JVM to provide us our data get like
spark and then we can use arrow to copy
it into one of these fine things and
emphasis on the issue with the
tensorflow part there's some
undocumented features that should be
fixed and actually there's there's a few
undocumented features here too
and we'll talk about those exciting
opportunities for improvement as it says
in my performance review shortly so we
all know that python is really good for
numeric computation and that is why
we're going to add the number one to
every element in this series because I
don't trust you have to do that in fact
I might actually get exceptions in Java
but that's a story for another time so
um we can use this this decorator and we
can still have our nice Python lambda
functions I mean here I gave it a name
has it's it's slightly easier than using
this decorator on a lambda there's
another thing that I can do but it's
it's kind of ugly
and when I do this in spark it will go
ahead and it will use arrow instead of
our really ancient hacks and this is
kind of Awesome
and I can actually use it to get a date
of a local data frame like view on a per
partition basis of my data that's
somewhat esoteric but essentially SPARC
splits up our data onto a whole bunch of
computers and if we ask it to group it
together in a certain way we'll end up
with the data about each key being
together inside of one partition and
then if I do this type of grouped map
operation it will let me take a look at
all of the data for that key on a
panda's data frame and I can use my
pandas operations finally for big data
yeah
pandas for big data I thought that was
gonna go oh yeah that's coming up later
um I thought that was gonna go over a
lot more excitingly I am clearly very
bad at judging this okay so that's a lot
of spark stuff how do other systems do
this
so Hadoop streaming which is not a
streaming system despite its name was
like yo I like UNIX pipes and it's kind
of sad but it turns out that MapReduce
was pretty bad anyways so we just didn't
notice so that was cool yeah overhead um
Casca gave us two options one of them
was a like reimplementation where I can
talk to Kafka and pure Python turns out
slow another one where I can talk to
Kafka in almost pure Python with C code
actually doing all of the work not that
slow but occasionally lags and features
and by occasionally lags and features
what I mean is has never achieved
feature parity and the final option of
we could use like Kefka streams and call
it with the terrible things we did
before but that's pretty terrible so all
of our options are bad here too
okay um and and now we come to desk desk
actually gives us data frames that look
like pandas dataframes and they often
quack like pandas dataframes
but occasionally they do make a
different sound and that's unfortunate
and leads to a runtime exception but
that's that's okay and if all you want
is a distributed data frame this is
really weird to say as a spark emitter
you probably actually want to ask spark
is cool and all but to ask is a really
much better job on distributed data
frames the only thing is the places
where they didn't is talking to the rest
of the Big Data ecosystem so if all you
need is a distributed data frame and
your data is like magically distributed
on a bunch of computers in like h5 files
or something you are good to go
if you want to talk to like something
that came out of school or like
MapReduce or or spark or something else
the next ya or v v1 + - I don't know
whatever
um it's not it doesn't yeah it doesn't
work for that but that's cool and
there's another system uh and it doesn't
work outside of Google just yet um but
we're totally gonna fix it
like for real there's code and it's
public it's just not in a release and
not only do we recreate all the same
mistakes that spark did we looked at
that and said you know what spark is
missing is docker cuz docker is really
really cool and what I want to do is I
want to docker eyes everything and so
yeah we got a lot of docker going on it
is a party and as much as I joke about
this this this actually addresses a
really interesting point in the in the
big data ecosystem most Hadoop cluster
administrators are lovely people who
have never heard of Python and when I go
to them and I'm like hey what's up I
need
our version of pandas they're like what
now Holden and I'm like no no pandas is
actually a thing not just something I
say when I'm drunk and then after a bit
of back and forth they'll upgrade it for
me once but they'll forget to do it on
like some of the machines and then I'm
kind of sad because my code just doesn't
work reliably um and darker gives us a
really nice way of being like these are
my dependencies
please ship them to all of my workers
for me and this this is a really
important problem to solve because we
didn't solve it yet anywhere else and if
you if you want to see the design
document where we went hey let's
recreate sparks errors but different um
you can check it out there and it is it
is gonna be a bit different and there's
this random collab branch which if you
want to click on will take you to some
random person's github where they've
been like hacking together making go
Python Java run on top of beam with
blink and it's just like also hilarious
to debug because you can pretty much
picture the spark story but was an extra
thing in the middle because everything
can be solved with another layer of
abstraction but as much as I joke about
this once these lines turn from orange
to black like it's going to be really
exciting because then we can actually
use actually are there any go users in
the house by chance I have three slides
for three people that's a good ratio and
we can actually use languages which
haven't traditionally been part of the
big data ecosystem even pythons like
been sort of riding along in the sidecar
but like maybe not not riding the
motorbike okay and so for those three go
developers yeah we can count words or
cow oh yeah the main point of this is to
illustrate that we can do pretty much
the same thing in languages besides
Python I probably actually in retrospect
should have picked our as the
in demo language um but the go
functionality was added like two weeks
ago so I was really excited about that
um but you can also just like rewrite
this into our your head and it's it's
pretty much the same thing so why are
these things starting to work now like
why is this starting to get better part
of it is like arrow exists there's
better formats but honestly there's
always been better formats than like
JSON for data interchange right like
we've always had better options they've
just gotten a lot better the other one
is I think the main driving factor is
that JVM developers are now faced with
the reality that they have to call
Python code to be able to raise their
next series of funding in San Francisco
and as such they're like well I need
this to work well enough to show to an
investor and that's not very well but it
is better than it worked before and so
we've seen a lot of improvements because
people want to use deep learning
libraries from Java and we can pretty
much take that stuff which is possibly
useful and use it for actually useful
things besides deep learning too the
other part is like Aero is awesome
and there's this other really cool thing
I don't know if anyone else is excited
by multi language pipelines people
excited for okay there's like for people
who are really excited for multi
language pipelines and multi language
pipelines are super super cool
mostly because I have to write in
multiple languages anyways
so everyone else should too but it's
more like python has some really really
great libraries but sodas are right and
sometimes most of what I want to do is
really well suited to Python but there's
like this tiny bit which would be so
much simpler to do in our right or vice
versa and it would be so much cooler if
that could just be one pipeline rather
than like doing some weird copying
between programs right and it
technically sort of works today and
we're gonna look at how it technically
sort of works with a demo project which
you can all definitely go and check out
on github and like laugh at the
delightful code and we'll talk about
also how it's gonna go from like kind of
painful to use to less painful to use
because that part is probably more
exciting that's when you're able go from
like looking at a demo project on github
and being like cool I never want to do
that to like cool I'm gonna use that in
my pipeline so this is where I introduce
sparkling ml we have this tradition in
the sparklin of naming things sparkling
X so there's like sparkling water from
the h2o company and sparkling ml I
didn't have a lot of good ideas and so
there's this panda wearing a hat cuz
we're gonna use it to get access to
pandas machine learning and do cool
things and so there's a panda wearing a
okay I guess when I have to explain my
logo that's probably not a great sign it
was from Fiverr and the idea behind
sparkling ml is essentially I work with
a lot of java people for better or worse
it is my life and I make no comments
because I know that they can search on
YouTube and find talks you know there
and there is a camp yeah okay there's
the camera and so that's cool but
sometimes when I'm working with the Java
people they have an NLP problem or they
have another problem where like the Java
solutions are just kind of like oh
they're really rough but the the Python
solutions are really awesome and I want
them to be able to use those Python
solutions inside of their code and we
can also use it in rivers if there's
like some really cool Java functionality
you want to get at inside of SPARC you
you can do it you pretty much just
ignore the underscore and you're like
what no that's fine it's totally normal
to type SC underscore JVM dot-com dot
like blah blah de blah blah dot new ins
and and yes you pretend this is normal
and you hope to god your cluster never
gets upgraded
it yeah so um the the TLDR of of this
ignore the underscores part is like we
can do this today but like don't do it
in a job you plan on keeping cuz then
you're gonna have to maintain that code
and that is gonna suck that that should
be future someone else's problem what
yes job security it's it's true um it
can be harder to I never want to be that
person though right that is how you
become the COBOL programmer maintaining
like this jaian payroll system or
something that's vitally important to
the company but oh dear God no one wants
to open and see how many monsters live
inside I'm gonna focus on exposing
Python functionality to Java because
people talk less about that but if you
want to see it the other way around you
can load a car inside of sparkling ml
and see examples of both I exposed the
lutein analyzers from Java in to Python
and leucine analyzers are almost always
worse than the specie analyzers but it's
you can see the how it's done if you had
Java code that you wanted to call the
main thing that we have to do is we have
to write it like this really ugly
startup file with a bunch of global
variables inside of it and a class which
implements a Java trait which is sorry
Java interface I spend too much time
with the Scala people so essentially we
write this wonderful thing called Python
registration provider which is the sign
that yes I have indeed once worked at an
enterprise shop and we say I expose this
package and this is what I implement and
that's fine right then the pipe then the
Java people know who to call and like
kind of what to expect back from us and
then we provide this like register
function which takes in the streaming
spark context I don't remember what I
wanted to be streaming whatever a Java
sparks session which is somehow distinct
don't worry about it the name of the
function they want and all of the / M
from Java serialized with pickling of
course pickling and then we go ahead and
we look this up in a kind of ugly table
and we okay let's let's skip the part
which is sad if anyone wants to read the
sad part the slides will be posted later
and then in the Java side we essentially
have an interface or if you're working
in Scala a trait which matches that
without the implementation detail and we
call this piece inside of SPARC to
construct our Python driver program even
if we're not using Python we just call
that same entry point when we do have to
pretend that we're inside a package org
Apache spark that's totally normal and
if you work in spark for long enough
you'll find out that you pretty much end
up having to do that at one point or
another because we've made a lot of
really bad decisions about what things
should be private and it's really boring
you can look at it if you want but let's
let's skip the boilerplate and go back
to counting words yes okay so one of the
things which feeds me early in my life
as a developer was I did this really
cool pipeline for building
recommendation systems for my glorious
employer at the time and then they came
to me and they were like hey Holden
that's great we saw like your
recommendations have increased whatever
metric by 0.0 0.0 flicked it about my
life and then they were like we want you
to take this to other markets and we
really want you to take this to the
Japanese market I'm like that's cool
I'll just like change the name of my
pipeline make a copy of it cuz like
copying code totally fine for
maintenance and I'll just tokenize that
oh dear I'll just tokenize and so it
turns out not every language does a
great job with tokenizing by spaces and
being the North American kid that I was
I I didn't realize that until my first
job and so that that went poorly but now
if I had the same problem again I could
just call Spacey rather than doing the
hack that we did which was like every to
care
the token whatever um I had no idea how
to judge the results
I seriously plug them into Google
Translate and was like this looks okay
whatever this is why you need a real
internationalization team but anyways so
now we can use cool functions that
support multiple languages oh I don't
know if you have the problem of multiple
languages in Europe I of course not
oh but yes this is this is the point um
and now we can call it from the JVM
right if I've made some cool things and
I'm working with a team that like is
maybe the production data team and
they're like this has to be in Java
because that's what our pipelines are I
can be like no no it's cool you can just
call my Python code let me show you how
please ignore startup I it is totally
normal
and if you want you can send them my
email and I'll be like yes very normal
and so we can go ahead and we can say
like hey this is the parameter that I
have like for the language these are my
input and output columns like please go
ahead and run this organization for me
and they do this right because you're a
very persuasive personality right you
you go to the engineering team and
you're like this was going to be so much
better than rewriting spacing in Java
and it is because we're running Spacey
and Java's impossible we could go back
to the chai thon thing to try and make
it go fast but then it turns out that
Jai thon and Spacey don't they're not
friends they had a fight and but it's
just not very fast but we could think
back to the earlier part of this
presentation where I talked about arrow
and instead of tokenizing individual
elements I can tokenize a series of
elements that is serialized with arrow
and then arrow will be super fast and
this will probably oh sorry I should
clarify linking run at 200 times faster
right we saw that in the slides yeah
okay this is now run 200 times faster um
it does run faster so alternatively you
might be like holding
I don't I don't care about my Java
friends like they can go Andrea
implements Pacey by themselves I just
want to use this really fast and we we
can just do the same thing that we did
before we use our pandas UDF decorator
and everything's happy here are the
references that's the github project
that I was talking about where you can
go and see all of this terrible code to
make it work it is hilarious I strongly
recommend it there is the expression
patches welcomed and they are but I
don't know why you bother and if you're
interested in learning more about the
space generally Apache arrow has a
pretty good site one of my former
co-workers has a really cool blog post
and we're approaching the most important
slide if anyone's really interested in
spark there are a large number of spark
books I am a co-author of a few of them
but it was only in my latest spark book
high-performance spark where I realized
you could negotiate royalties with
publishers like for real they'll pay you
different amounts just for asking and so
I get a lot more money on this book and
I think it is a great book yeah um it is
not overly relevant but that should not
stop you from buying it with your
corporate credit card okay if you want
to come see me in any of these places
these are places that I will be in the
future I sincerely hope that this place
is actually on a beach I do not know
okay on the beach it is really on a
beach or not I will be upset if it is
not and I'll be back for straddle London
to talk about spark auto-tuning with my
co-author and there's not like a super
lot of time left based on the little
timer thing I think there's like time
for maybe one question and if anyone
wants to find me you can probably pick
me out of the crowd here
my shoes light up and yes so come come
find me later with questions unless we
want to do like one really quick one
right now does anyone have like a really
quick question okay
oh there is one really quick question
amazing tooks thank you what do you
think about Ray it's also uses arrow and
it's kind of like similar to dusk what
what should we choose now like that is a
great question I think Ray is really
interesting I love research projects
[ __ ] I I guess that answered it um the
TLDR is I think it's really cool but I
don't think it's a thing that I would
run in production today
that being said like I think it's a
thing that will either be abandoned in a
year or something that I want to run in
a year and I don't know which way it's
gonna go probably depends on how long it
takes the grad students to finish their
theses
[Applause]
oh I forgot to tell everyone about boo
I'm sorry this is boo she's my
co-presenter and she travels with me
everywhere her name is boo thang
[Applause]